Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today is an episode of Rawkode Live where
we are taking a look at a new
open source tool from the team at Robusta
to help you improve your Kubernetes resource optimization.
To guide us through our demo today, I
am joined by Nathan.
Hello. How are you?
Good. It's a pleasure to be here. Yeah.
What is this? Stream number is three together,
I think. So, you know, five months ago,
we looked at
oh, what was it? Kubernetes monitoring.
And a year ago, took a look at
robusta. So pleasure to have you back.
Pleasure is mine. Yeah. I
it a lot has happened since then both
in terms of Robusta and also my personal
life. I
just have a newborn baby at home now,
so it just feels like it's been so
much longer.
Well, congratulations.
It's a wonderful thing.
A hard thing, but a wonderful thing.
Yes. Thank you. For anyone who is you
know, hasn't seen any of our previous episodes
as in familiar review and your work, which,
you know, shame on them. You're doing some
great stuff right now in the Kubernetes space,
and people should definitely be checking out your
blog and stuff. But do you wanna give
people the TLDR and share whatever you'd like
to share?
Yeah. So what we do at Robust or
rather, I'll start with the problem. The problem
is that
there's two problems. The first problem
is that people have all this observability data.
Mean, sometimes
terabytes of observability data that's sitting there. But
when there's an incident and when something's going
on in production, then finding the right thing
to look at finding the right thing to
look at fast is often very difficult.
So what we do at robust is to
try and help you take your observe observability
there and your existing observability data in Prometheus
and other places
and to extract from that meaningful,
and actionable insights.
And
there's several ways that, like, that comes about.
So we have an open source project,
that
takes your Prometheus alerts and then, adds on
extra data and ties it to logs and
so on. Then there's KRR, which we're gonna
look at today, which is about taking your
existing Prometheus data and using that to now
extract insights about efficiency and about CPU request
to memory. And, of course, we have a
commercial platform as well.
Awesome.
Well, I think we have Pavan and Elbe
at the chat. Elbe says congrats, and Pavan
says hello, who I believe is on the
robust dot team. Right?
Awesome.
So today, as you said, we're taking a
look at KRR, a tool for Kubernetes Resource
Optimization,
trying to help people with scaling workloads within
our cluster. But maybe before we dive into,
like, the demo and talk about what KRR
does, we can kind of understand what the
challenges are right now with workloads with Kubernetes
and, you know, resource requests and vertical pod
auto scaling. There's a whole bunch of stuff
that isn't really there by default. Right? It's
not like you just create your deployment, you
get your pods and and things magically work.
I mean, they could,
but as your cluster grows and more workloads
come on and the older your cluster is
and the more teams you onboard,
there's a plethora of challenges that are inevitably
gonna come your way. So, you know, what's
your experience of working with Kubernetes, onboarding new
workloads, and where do things start to click
and fall apart?
So there are a few stories here. The
first story is that
we
we had this.
You'd expect this as we move to the
cloud. Right? And we adapt all this great
technology, and we adapt Kubernetes, and we adapt
all these things.
Then you'd actually see that we're as, like,
an industry, we're becoming more efficient,
and we're becoming more reliable.
But in fact, if you look, like, at
the past year, then we've only seen the
opposite happen with incident after incident after incident.
Just last week, Instagram
just this week, I think Instagram was down
for a couple of hours.
And, like, what you see is that we're
not like, we'd expect that we're adopting all
this great technology. You're going to Kubernetes. You're
getting all these great things, and then your
system is becoming better. But instead,
there's all this added complexity.
And I think a lot of that complexity
is just ifying. It's good. You're getting these
benefits. You're getting, like, all those scaling. You're
getting all this stuff. But to set it
up and to configure it can sometimes be
a little bit bit challenging.
And then if you, like, double click on
that and you zoom really in, like, specifically
on Kubernetes and scaling, then there are two
things that you're always trying to balance. So
on the one hand, you wanna have something
that's really efficient, so you don't wanna allocate
all these resources that you don't need. On
the other hand, though, you wanna guarantee reliability,
and those always come hand in hand. And
there's, like, a trade off between them. And
what I mean by that is let's say
you have one application
that requires,
like, 10 c that requires one CPU, and
occasionally, it requires two CPU. Right? Then if
you give it two CPU,
then you're gonna satisfy the reliability. Right? And
maybe sometimes it speaks up it's can spike
to three CPU. So give it 10 CPU.
Give it a hundred CPU. Right? You're never
gonna have a reliability issue,
but you're gonna have a cost and efficiency
issue. On the other hand, if you take
that same workload
that requires one CPU most of the time,
you just give it one CPU.
Now you're gonna run into reliability issues when
it needs two. And all of the different
technologies involved in, like, an HPA and the
VPA and scaling and cluster other skin and
all that is about trying to
balance those constraints, and you balance it each
time in different ways. But there are always,
always trade offs, and I think that's important
to understand that that you will never have
a % efficiency
and a % reliability
because by definition, there's a conflict between the
two of those. Because with reliability,
you're looking at the 1% edge case. And
with efficiency, you're looking at the 99 case.
Yeah. I mean, I guess to try and
summarize that in, like, a single line. Right?
To understand that trade off is that you
you could get really good resiliency and redundancy
and all of that stuff on the happy
path, but it's the expensive path. Like, you
over provision 300, four hundred, six hundred percent,
whatever you want. If you've got the money
and you wanna throw it away or set
it on fire, sure. Go for it. Like,
yeah. You're you're gonna have a better time.
Maybe not an easy time, but a better
time than most. However, most organizations
can't just over provision to that kind of
level. They wanna reduce costs when they migrate
to the cloud. In fact, cost is usually
a
portion of why they're doing this. You know,
they're making the swap for operational
expenditure versus capital expenditure or whatever that term
is. I'm not a business person. So then
what they wanna do is, well, they set
all these resource requests so that they say,
okay. I expect these workloads to do this.
We have a buffer of 20%, thirty %,
whatever that is for your team. And then
you try to scale within that and scale
your cluster and your pods at the same
time. But that's the tricky path. That's the
hard path because it's
your workloads constantly move. They constantly change. They
constantly nodes or ephemerals are not always gonna
be there. All of these things really start
to compound and provide a pretty strong challenge
for your platform or SRE team to keep
the cluster healthy, the workload's healthy, and your
customers happy.
Yes.
So you can choose two out of three.
Right? It's always choose two out three. So
you have reliability,
efficiency,
and simplicity.
And I say you can choose two out
of three because you can get close with
efficiency
and with reliability and, like, kind of trying
to have both of them, but then you
go up in terms of complexity. Like, if
you think of a think of your cluster
as a pizza party, then either and you're
throwing a party and you don't know how
many people are gonna show up. So either
you order more pizzas and you end up
throwing some of them away, that's the trade
off with efficiency,
or you order,
like, the lower bound of pizzas, and then
people come there hungry, so that's your liability.
Or you do something complex where you're, like,
you're counting how many people come in the
door and you're looking at pizzas, then you
have delivery guy coming back and forth every
hour, and that's the trade off for the
simplicity.
But let's take that now into Kubernetes, and,
like, let's zoom in on Kubernetes.
So I wanna take an example.
Actually, I wanna take some statistics from a
recent cystic study, and they looked at all
the people running Kubernetes in production
that they have access to based on data
center system. They looked at all these giant
environments and lots of clusters, and they categorized
it by, like, big business and small business
and enterprise.
And if they're all these companies, what they
found is that 69%
of all the CPU that people are paying
for is actually wasted,
and that's an incredible number. And then to
translate this, though, people don't see that because,
like, you open up MENS or you look
at your cluster,
and you don't see you're not you're not
seeing anywhere 60
69% waste. What you see instead is you
go and you look at a node, and
you see, like, your node is full.
And
there's no room on your node, maybe you
have pending pods. But then you, like, look
into the node, you see the CPU is
at 10%, and you have low utilization.
So to understand all that, I think you
need to start at the basics,
which is setting just two numbers on Kubernetes.
Everything comes down to ultimately setting
two numbers, arguably four numbers. But we'll we'll
start with the two basics. Right? And that's
your CPU request and your memory request. And
the way to think about this for people
who aren't familiar is you're telling Kubernetes in
advance how much CPU will you need for
this pod and how much memory will you
need for this pod. And that's just the
request. It's just used by the scheduler to
decide which node it should put your pod
on.
Nice.
So
so so the reason why we're here today
and what we're doing with with KRR is
we're just trying to help you set those
two numbers.
Oh, it's a noble a noble mission. I'm
curious, though. Right? Like,
what where were you setting? What were you
doing when you were like, alright. Let's write
a new open source tool that goes and
does what KRR does. Like, what was the
motivation? How how
how did you decide this is my next
thing that I'm gonna build?
So it
came up because we heard again and again
from people who were using robust and were
using other stuff,
or other platforms.
And
they came to us again and again. They
said, okay. How can I set CPU requests?
How can I set memory requests? And what
should they be? And the reason it came
up is because we have alerts in robust
about reliability issues.
We didn't do anything related to efficiency, but
we have these reliability alerts.
Like, you're having CPU throttling because your request
is wrong or because
you set the limit that's blocking that. So
we started getting reliability questions,
and very often, the answer to that reliability
question was you need to set their
you need to set your allocations differently. You
need to, like, allocate more CPU up front
for this, or you need to allocate more
memory up front for this in order to
make sure it runs smoothly.
And we tell people that, then they come
back and say, okay. Well, what should I
put in for the CPU request? What should
I put in for the memory request?
And
our answer was always like, okay. Well, look
at the vertical pod autoscaler. Look at these
these other systems.
And
we kept on hearing from people, no. That's
not working for me because of x, y,
and z. That's not working for me because
I can't actually use the VPA because I'm
using an HPA at the same time. Or
I wanna use the VPA,
but how do I know, like, when there's
a new recommendation I should apply that's off
by 20%?
Or I wanna use the VPA,
but I wanna get recommendations that are stable
over time that aren't constantly changing. So we
started hearing about this, and
the first thought we had in our mind
was, okay. We're gonna take the VPA. For
people who don't know, the VPA or the
vertical pilot autoscaler,
was in
I think, like, until KRR, I think, just
the probably the only real way at scale
to determine this stuff in your cluster determine
request limits.
I'm
probably forgetting something. I shouldn't say that. I'm
probably forgetting other tools out there. But it
was the number one way.
Yeah. I mean, there are other tools out
there that don't actually integrate natively with Kubernetes
like Parker, which can profile our application and
tell you what values are over time. But
you still have to do the analysis. You
still have to kinda look at that and
work it out and configure it on VPN
and stuff like that. So definitely, there's a
lot of room for
tooling to improve and make this easier for
teams.
And there are proprietary solutions out there as
well, I should say. There are proprietary
solutions, I think, specifically for Kubernetes
that also can do it. But there there
was no other than the VPA, I think,
like, there was no open source way that
that we like to do it. And then
the first thought that went through our head,
and I said to the team, like, we're
not developing this from scratch. I I was
pretty stubborn for a very long time with
the team. The team said we need to
develop an alternative to the VPA. I said,
we're not developing an alternative to the VPA.
Take the output of the VPA and add
on reporting features, give a better experience, but
we are not developing an alternative to the
VPA. It doesn't make sense.
And,
eventually, I caved because
we looked at it, and we really looked
at it from the product requirements and, like,
from the product spec and what we wanted
to accomplish with this, and we discovered we
couldn't do it on top of the VPA.
So I was kinda dragged kicking and screaming
and, like, objecting the entire way and said,
okay. You know what? We will do our
own recommendations engine.
Okay.
So
I'm not that familiar with KRR.
Is it a replacement for the VPA?
We do. That's
Sorry. We
No. Go on. Yeah.
Sorry. I I like so I I seen
the announcement. I went on the GitHub page.
I kinda give it a scan. You know
how I like to do these, James? Like,
I I like to come out with fresh
eyes and really learn from from you, right,
rather than trying to make my own assumptions
upfront. But from what I've seen is is
a command I run locally, and there's nothing
in the cluster. So I
I I didn't come into this. It's back
not to replace the VPA. I saw it
to be something that gave me, like, a
VPA
starting point or something. I wasn't I wasn't
actually that sure. So maybe you can correct
some of my assumptions then.
So the VPA has two modes. One mode
is it runs in cluster, and it's constantly
monitoring your pods. It's very heavily weighing its
recommendations
towards the last twenty four hours.
You can tune that, of course, but that's
the default.
And
then it's constantly, like, updating your pods.
And that we're not doing. Like, we decide,
at least in phase one, we are not
we are not modifying anything in production. We
are read only. We will give you a
recommendation,
but it's up to you to apply that
recommendation to review it. And this is a
human in the loop process.
So we're not competing with the BPA that
runs in cluster.
But we actually did some studies.
Like, I did some surveys on LinkedIn, and
we had a valid user interviews.
And we discovered that most people aren't running
the VPA in in,
like, the
automatic mode. Most people are running the VPA
in your recommendation mode where the VPA gives
recommendations, and then the human looks at it.
And then you go and you apply that.
So for that mode,
we are competing with it. We just don't
make you run something constantly in your cluster.
Ah, got it. Okay.
Nice.
So that that comes back to also, like,
why we had to build this ourselves even
though I was very
very much against it at the beginning. To
use the VPA, you have to install something
in cluster, and you start getting recommendations
in the future.
Whereas most people already have a cluster. Like,
I have a cluster here set up locally
now.
It's had Prometheus forever.
I'm when I show KRR in a few
minutes, I'm just gonna run KRR on the
historical data, and I'm gonna get the recommendations
immediately.
And that ties back to what we wanna
do with Robusta, which is you have all
this observability data.
I wanna unlock,
like, the goal that's already hidden there. So
we wanted to make it as easy as
possible. We wanted to give you a command
you run locally. We didn't wanna make like,
add on any friction for running something in
your cluster because maybe you don't have permissions
to do so.
Okay.
Well, I guess we can dive straight into
the demo,
or I can guess what we're gonna see.
It's entirely up to you. But based on
you've you've mentioned Prometheus. You've mentioned KARs or
CLI tool. I'm assuming it's
a nice way of running queries against
workloads on Prometheus to get top, middle, bottom
values across in a certain amount of time
and then make recommendations based on top of
that. Yep. That's right. So let me just
let me clear
my screen, and I'm gonna share my screen.
Let's see. Yeah. Go for it.
And
let me blow this up. Can you see
my terminal window? I am just going to
make that happen.
Alright. Now we see your terminal. But can
you make the font a little bit bigger,
please? Yes. I will. There we go. Perfect.
And can you see I wanna get over
here. Let's see if it follows. So this
is just the GitHub.
So
first thing I wanna do, just to give
you a teaser, this is what we're gonna
get.
What we're gonna get in just a minute
is we're gonna get these recommendations. So for
everything that's running in my cluster,
I'm gonna find out what should be the
CPU request, the CPU limits, memory request, and
their memory limits.
And this is based on the historical Prometheus
data.
So let's go back, though. So the first
thing I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
install this. And I can install this a
few different ways.
I can either install via Brew,
or I can install by just cloning the
code. So I'm gonna just clone the codes.
And there we go.
And I'm gonna go back now, and I'm
gonna install the requirements.
And this is with Python. Of course, you
don't have to have Python. You could just
use
you could just use, the prebuilt binaries, so
you don't actually have to have Python to
run this.
Whoops. Clear. And I'm gonna go back. Finally,
I'm just gonna copy this command.
And I believe in my case, it has
to be Python 3.9.
And I'm not gonna get anything by default.
It's gonna ask me to choose a strategy.
And right now, we have one strategy that
we call simple,
and this is the strategy
for how we calculate
what the CPU and the memory should be.
So
the default strategy and the first strategy that
we implemented, it will find the maximum amount
of memory,
and it's gonna use that as the baseline
for how much memory you your pod should
get, the maximum amount that they've used in
the past.
And for CPU,
it's gonna go, and I believe I will
have to zoom out to get something formatted
nicely.
Yep.
So let's just run that again.
And for CPU, it's gonna go and it's
gonna take the 99 percentile. So what we're
trying to do here is we're trying to
understand based on historical data, how much CPU
and memory your pods need. And then by
setting that number right,
then we're going to be able to reduce
costs while still maintaining reliability.
And that is really all there is to
it. So I just ran that, and it's
connected to Prometheus in my cluster, found it
automatically. So I didn't need to point out
Prometheus. I didn't need to do anything.
And
it went and it looked at each of
the workloads running in cluster,
and then it queried them in Prometheus.
And it found here the historical data, and
it's telling me what I should set based
on that historical data.
Nice.
So if I take an example here,
then here's an example, the Argo CD application
set controller. And right now, that has no
CPU request, so it's telling me,
one, I should set a CPU request, and
two, based on historical data, the right amount
for this would be five milli CPU.
The memory request is on set, but based
on the historical data, what this needs is
20 is 23
megabytes
of memory. And then for limits, for CPU
and memory limits, and there are different approaches
to how you set that. And there
is some controversy around that around different opinions.
But
we
have some options also that we're going to
expose for how you can control that.
Nice.
So it scans that cluster. It gives me
recommendations.
I can pump them straight into my GitOps
pipeline, and off I go. I got the
happier cluster. Right?
Yep.
Yeah. I think what's
interesting here is, like, you know, I work
guess I'm in a a unique position, right,
as a consultant these days. Right? I don't
work on my own cluster. I spend a
lot of my time working with everyone else's
clusters,
which is a blessing and a curse. But
what I've seen
constantly
is that people really overestimate
their CPU requests on all of their workloads.
Like, you know, usually, they're straight in there
with the 500 millicores, you know, half of
half a core. And you're like, like, why?
Like, that's that's a lot of CPU to
be thrown into your, you know, three meg
go application that runs once every fifteen seconds
or whatever.
And I think just having tools like this
that can get people visibility and to actually
what the average application really needs from a
CPU request kind of view is is much
less. Like, I I don't think I've ever
seen someone with a cluster that applies five
m as their CPU.
And I think that's very eye opening. I
hope it's eye opening for people that you
don't need to go nuts with this. And
even where it's not 500, they set it
to 200 or they set it to, like,
one fifty. It's like, it's always very high
numbers.
And there's I'll call out GKE here for
being notoriously bad. But if you run, sorry,
GKE. But if you run an autopilot cluster,
it actually does, like, automatic VPA for you.
And, that over provisions by a factor of
10 based on what I've seen as well.
Like, it's it's it's hugely over provisioning.
Yep. We've gotten some feedback from people that
we should over provision a little bit more,
to give a little more buffer. So we're
actually considering changing it from, like, five m
to 50 m.
But if you look at the big scale
of it, it's not even the 50 m
versus the five m. Right? Because how many
applications do you really have with five m
or 50 m? It's with those 500 megabyte
or those one core
machines.
And if you go back to that cystic
study, sixty nine percent is over provisioned on
CPU.
So take a typical company that has a
cloud bill of, let's say, don't
know, let's say 5 k a month on
GKE,
right, or on AWS or on Kubernetes.
So if you're paying 5 k a month
and you're let me just do the math
now. And you're 69%
over provisioned,
then
you're paying almost 3.5
k extra a month.
So more than half of like, that's slicing
more your cloud bill in more than half.
Yep.
Yeah. I
don't know. I I don't think I would
go from 5 m to 50 m even
if people are calling. I need to speak
higher.
Like, I would encourage people, you you know,
run KRR, but then back it up. Run
cube control top pods
and see the low numbers for the current
utilization of CPU. Like, it's never that high
unless you've got a Java workload in there
in which you've got other problems. I'm really
sorry. But, you know, you you don't need
high levels of CPU requests
for most of them. So this is what
I'm actually the most excited about in terms
of what we're working on.
You get a recommendation like this.
The first thing that you're gonna go and
do afterwards is you wanna validate this recommendation.
Right?
And you're gonna go and you're gonna look
at historical graph of this data. And then
based on that historical graph, you're gonna, like,
draw a line across that and say, okay.
How would I perform on this recommendation in
the past three three weeks? Right?
So
we're actually it's, like, being worked on the
right right now that I really wanted to
show on the show today, but it wasn't
on time. But just any day now, we're
gonna have this out, is to be able
to also show you the justification for these
recommendations to, like, show you it on a
graph and then to draw a dotted line
across, say, like, okay. Here's what we're recommending,
and then this is how that would perform
in historical data.
And
so that's one of the things that we're
working on right now that I'm really excited
about. Because like you said, you're not gonna
just go and apply this recommendation probably. You
wanna see why. Right? You wanna visualize it.
You wanna go through and do this whole
process.
And then when we think about, like, how
we
how we give you recommendations, it's not just
about giving you the recommendation and the number.
It's about giving you the confidence to apply
it.
Yeah. Definitely.
And, like, if we go back to what
you said at the start of this demo.
Right? Like, you're doing Prometheus request. You're looking
how long did you say the status over?
Like, what? Three months or longer? Is it
all time? So it depends on your it
depends on your prometheus. Yeah.
Yeah. So if you got a retention policy
of, say, three weeks or maybe it's thirty
days, it doesn't really matter. I mean, this
is the max value over that retention policy.
So but I think that's that's really cool
for people just to really get that front
and center. Like, you maybe don't need to
draw a graph in the terminal to even
just pop them a link and say, look
at this and yourself.
It's like, go and take a look and
see. And then maybe what maybe in some
cases, you know, we do see a couple
of large numbers there. You've got your
platform
relay using 261.
Right?
That could have been a spike for thirty
second window two weeks ago. Like, you really
don't You wanna see it. Yeah. You wanna
see it. But so I'll tell you something
that's very interesting. When
you look at what's the maximum,
actually depends a lot on what time periods
you're looking at. So imagine that you say,
I'm gonna just go into Grafana,
and I'm gonna look at a two week
period.
And then in that two week period in
like, if I'm looking at Grafana, I'm gonna
take the maximum, right, of CPU.
But it actually
like, what that maximum is actually depends on
what your interval is that you're sampling at.
Because
imagine you have a pod that, it, like,
runs and it's doing nothing all the time,
and then it spikes
for just one second, and it goes all
the way up to 10 CPU, and then
it goes back down. And now you take
it and you graph this data over two
week periods.
And when you're graphing over two week period,
you're, like, taking one hour intervals and the
average over each hour. So you're never gonna
see that spike on that graph. It's just
gonna be a flat zero the entire time.
Yeah. And I think that's still okay. Right?
I mean,
these TPU requests are a scheduling concern. They're
not a runtime concern.
It's not like your application can consume
above these requests. So
they're they're there to help us schedule or
so you don't over provision nodes and you
reduce a class of problems that probably don't
really need to exist.
Well, considering the cost factor of just a
finitely scaling the number of nodes that you
have.
We have a question from Russell in the
chat. So I'm gonna pop that up. But
Russell asked,
does this tool or could this tool, I
guess, have a report that shows the idle
time of each node? So, you know, really
trying to hammer home that point about that
69%
nonutilization.
Like, can you show that on a node
basis or pod basis for these workloads? I
think that that's a good question.
Yes. So so not yet, but, yeah, I
mean, it's also coming. So
when you think and it also matters so
it's both on the node level and the
pod level. Like, on the node level,
you wanna understand, like, what's the utilization? What's
the idle time? Right? Like, how well am
I doing or is my company or team
doing
as a whole when it comes to efficiency?
Like, am I doing nine out of 10,
and then I'm not gonna worry about improving
this as much?
Or am I doing, like, one out of
10, and then I should really go and
focus on this? So we don't yet show
the nodes, but it's something that's being planned.
And then to tie into what you said
about the pods, it's not just the number
here. Like, if this number matters,
it actually is the difference here times the
number of pods.
Because think about it. Like, if you have
an application, a replica set that has a
hundred replicas.
Yeah. And you have a hundred megabyte difference
on all of them, then it's actually a
hundred times,
like,
a hundred megabytes. So it comes up to
be bigger.
Yeah.
That those number could get crazy pretty quickly,
actually.
You know? So
you
mentioned that this is a simple strategy and
that more strategies are gonna come. I'm assuming
you're looking into things like linear prediction, whole
winters, other statistical proxies for understanding
growth over time, averages over time, etcetera. Maybe
you could talk about what's coming, or what
ideas you've got for other strategies.
Yeah. Okay. So imagine I'll I'll give you
a scenario,
mate.
And don't say OpenAI chat GPT. I don't
wanna hear that. I'm not gonna say it.
I'm gonna say it. Then I just see
Russell said here in the chat that you
wanna see over time so you can see
your nose on something like 30% average.
And then on times, can go up to
70%. So, yeah, absolutely.
I don't know if that's
I don't know if that's something we're gonna
expose in the CLI or if it's something
we're gonna show in the SaaS platform. Maybe
I can just share my screen
for a second. And I still wanna answer
your question about the strategies.
I mean Yeah. Of course. Let me see.
Alright. So I'm gonna answer the question about
the strategies after first, and then maybe I'll
show something else afterwards.
So
imagine you have a workload now,
where you're running this workload and, like, every
weekend, it does nothing. Right?
And then the entire week, it goes and
it's, like, burning CPU or it has some
psych thickness. Right?
So
what you wanna do is you wanna apply
an algorithm, let's say, like, winters. Right? And
you wanna understand the, like, the you wanna
understand that there's some psychic behavior here, and,
like, there's some period periodicity.
Then on certain days, it performs a different
way. But you can't go and just set
a request and then limit because when you're
sending a request and then limit, you're sending
a flat value.
So in order to do this properly,
then what you have to do is you
have to have two parts that go hand
in hand together. On the one hand, you
have a better algorithm that understands the historical
data.
But on the other hand, your output, it
has to be richer output
than
just getting, like, just getting the request in
a moment. And then there are two approaches
you can go with this. Like, the first
approach is, okay. We're gonna run write this
really complicated Kubernetes operator,
and we're gonna apply all these different stuff
dynamically in cluster. We're gonna do it time
based, or we're do it based on, like,
what's coming into Kafka now. We're gonna do
it based on the CPU loads.
But,
actually, all that already exists. Like, if I
wanna do it scale based on time, then
KEDA has this really cool thing called, like,
a time scaler.
And I can say with CADA, this patch
run however many replicas on this day of
the week. On this day of the week,
it shouldn't run at all. On this day
of the week, it should run five times
as many replicas.
So
what we wanna do with other strategies
is to have strategies that have better algorithms.
And in terms of the output, though, we're
not giving you just a request in limit.
We're giving you an HPA config. We're giving
you a KLA config. We're giving you like,
we're generating the KLA or the HPA config
for for you based on that historical data.
Yeah. I think that would be really powerful.
You know, go back to the the example
that you were talking about. Let's assume your
ecommerce store that your traffic sets at five
m
for eleven months of the year or ten
months of the year. Right? But then at
Black Friday and over Christmas, you've got these
incredible spike in traffic and sales and you
don't wanna lose track you don't wanna lose
anything. Right? You don't wanna lose money just
because your infrastructure can't cope. This is for
a whole bunch of some of them really
excel because they can detect that the cycle
within the data and what's the
what the effect and other factors are if
you have that kind of data. So I
think it'd be really cool to have that
kind of thing in KRR.
And, again, this comes down to people having
retention periods and doing downsampling of their metrics,
which I think is a whole other world
of stuff that people need to get better
at. I think Prometheus has
has just taught people to have a thirty
day retention window, only look back thirty days.
But, actually, you need to be done sampling
that they unsore in it for long term
analysis over twelve, twenty four, thirty six months.
And really, if you wanna get good at
the stuff, that is, of course. But
having KRR be able to understand that, work
with that data, and create a KRR profile
would be really, really cool,
especially for these use cases where there are
a lot of ecommerce companies where they have
to scale up at Black Friday and at
Christmas. There are seasonal companies like holiday travel
agents that get really busy when people want
to pick their summer holidays.
There are Scottish people who just drink a
lot of whiskey at New Year, and, of
course, that's gonna take traffic somewhere on the
Internet. Maybe Twitter. Who knows? But, you know,
this opens that all up. So that's a
really cool enhancement. I'd love to see that
come. KRR.
And especially, who can indicate that because KRR
is a really cool project in this space
as well. So
I can say that, like, as a now
as someone who used to be a developer
and someone, like, who occasionally has to set
the values in these.
There's,
like, a black art to how you determine
the right k to configure, how you determine
the right HBA
scaler.
And
what we wanna do is we wanna make
it all, like, really simple. So if I
I take it back to, like, where we
started this conversation and people are moving to
the cloud and you're moving to Kubernetes and
the cloud is supposed to bring you all
these awesome cost savings.
And then you look at it, and you
have these nodes that are at 30% utilization.
Right?
Mhmm. It didn't deliver on that promise.
And a big part of what we're trying
to do is with open source software and
with your existing observability data, let's say, okay.
Yeah. There's some added complexity here
with Kubernetes
and,
of course, with the cloud and with Keta
and with HPA. All these things add complexity,
but we can get you to this maximum
that is way, way better than where you
were when you were running on prem where
you had your own data center.
But
you have to be able to take that
data in to be able to extract meaningful
insights from that.
So
is this that's something kicking around in my
head. And I know you've said, right, that
you were dragged kicking and screaming into not
working with the VPA.
And you've also told us on the stream
that, you know, you don't it's read only.
You don't want to modify a cluster.
But I'm sitting here and I'm looking like,
I have a robusta in my cluster already.
Right? You know, there's there's an operator that
does things.
Would you not
would you not look at just kind of
broadening the scope a little bit and trying
to
who can to, like, create in these horizontal
pod things, updating objects in Kubernetes cluster. Is
that not something
I mean, you're you're you're right there. Right?
It's like open that door. Are you gonna
open that door? You gonna just keep it
shut? I'm not sure.
Okay. So the big question here is GitOps.
I mean, but I will put GitOps aside
for a second. Okay?
We're open to generating these HPA like, to
generating HPA or to generating a KDA config.
We're
open to creating,
like, the what you need in order to
scale. What we don't wanna do is we
don't wanna be the one who's, like, constantly
watching that pod and then scaling it. We
wanna reuse what's already there in KTH or
HBI.
Okay. Cool.
I think that was closer to a yes
than a no, but I'll leave that up
to interpretation of anyone watching. So
I Did you sorry. On you go.
No. I there's is there some lag here,
or is it just on on my end?
I'm curious. No. I've noticed a little bit
of lag too. I don't know if it's
just the Internet. I don't know if it's
the streaming software. I don't know if it's
the weather. Who knows? But so far,
I don't think we've dropped anything, so I
think we're okay.
You said you were possibly gonna show something
else. Would you like to do that now?
I mean, so we're also sending this data
to the robust SaaS platform. And,
I mean, I just wanna show a few
other ways that you can use this actually.
So I wanna start with stack reports.
Are you sharing your screen? Sorry.
Yeah. I'm about to start sharing it. Alright.
Okay.
So I wonder if the DAG might be
on my end because my browser is freezing
up.
But Let me see.
One moment. I'm just gonna pull this up.
Yeah. Of course.
Okay. So I wanna start,
with
another use case that's come up that we've
heard from a lot of people,
which is
okay. I ran KRR,
and I, like, I got a report once.
But what happens if two weeks from now,
some new applications,
like,
is deployed to the cluster or something goes
way off, two weeks from now and something
changes in one of my applications?
So what we've actually done is we've done
an integration with our other open source software
for robusta. It's, like you said, already running
cluster.
So we can then do a scan on
on a specific schedule that you set, like,
let's say, a week. And then we generate
a PDF report for that, and we just
send it over to you in Slack.
Can you hear me, David?
Yeah. I think you may be dropped off
for a second there now, but you're back.
Okay. So you generate a PDF report and
you send over?
Let me let me refresh my screen for
one second. I might drop out of the
call, but I think that'll fix the
issue. Is that okay? Of course.
Okay. Welcome back.
Yeah. Okay. Am I back in the livestream?
You are indeed.
Okay. So let's try that again.
So, yeah, what I was saying is, one
thing that we want you to do is
we wanna help you put this on autopilot
and then kind of forget about it until
there's something else that requires your attention.
So one thing that you can do that
I don't think we're highlighting enough in the
main repo yet is you can configure a
scan that runs periodically,
like, once a week.
And
when that happens, then you just get a
report here in stock, and you can go
over that and and then see any new
recommendations.
Oh, nice. Okay. So Robusta and Cluster does
the KRR scan for you, and then you
can get
a nice little report whenever you want, showing
you how good or how bad your current
setup is. Right? Exactly.
So we're sending that to two different places.
The first is to stack for people who
are just using the open source side. So
we wanna make sure they have a way
to get periodic weekly recommendations.
And then the other thing we're doing is
for people who are using, the UI,
which is part of our SaaS offering,
then we're also sending stuff,
over here. And here, you can see the
same recommendations,
in the SaaS platform.
Oh, cool.
Nice.
And there's value add to the SaaS platform
now then.
Yep.
Mean,
I think, like, philosophically,
then we wanna make sure that we're always
balancing the two things. Like, on the one
hand, adding functionality to the SaaS, but on
the other hand, making sure that people also
have a workaround and they can still get
this in a pure open source way if
they want.
Yeah. And I think it gives people the
ability to kinda onboard themselves to this flow
at their own pace. Like, if you just
want to run KRR once a month from
a developer's laptop,
sure. Right? But once you get a bit
more, I don't know, confidence
and you wanna start pushing that more through
more automation,
you get the report. And then, you know,
I'm sure we'll be chatting in six months
time when robust is just hooking into Kira
and doing other cool stuff too. So looking
forward to seeing that in the future.
I wish I wish we were there already,
but it's gonna take some time. But I
it's one of the things that most excites
me being able to, like, even just speak
to people at conference and just having a
casual conversation. Someone says to me, like, okay.
Well,
how should I set like, how should I
scale this microservice that's new here? And just
say, like, run one command. You're done. It'll
check, like, five different strategies. It'll tell you
what's most optimal. It'll give you the menu.
You can look it over and choose, or
you can take the first one if you
don't wanna think about it.
I wanna be able to say to people,
like, you're now speaking as someone who's, like,
an advocate for Kubernetes, I wanna be able
to say to people, like,
scaling is a no brainer. Like, there's you
don't even need to think about it. Like,
you wanna configure all the scanning? Just run
one command. Don't think about it. You wanna
configure KDA? Just run one command. Don't think
about it.
Nice. Awesome.
So
I've finished with one last question.
Right now,
we then actually dive into, like well, we
did. Right? It's it's looking into the metrics
of the I guess, this is from metric
server from the Kuplet where it's looking at
CPU utilization and the memory utilization.
Is there a future where it tries to
go beyond those metrics and actually, like, take
a look at the
it should be latency to understand, well, actually,
you're only using this much CPU,
but if maybe that's because there's other things
in place, maybe the CPU limits or whatever
or contention,
but your latency is quite high. And it's
like, well, okay. Well, you could probably bring
this latency down by allocating more CPU or
maybe even it's running on a different type
of hardware. Like, maybe how maybe there's cloud
awareness that comes into KRR that says you're
running on, like, a XS
tiny box on Amazon with, a one megabit
network card. Maybe
you need to start looking at bigger ones.
Maybe you need gigabit A four nets. Maybe
you need multiple A four nets because you've
got a lot of contention on a single
box. Maybe you need to switch to ARM
process. I don't know. Like, there's a whole
wealth of stuff out there. Like, scheduling isn't
just taking the hardware that we have. It's
capacity
planning and looking at how do we improve
that. And I wonder, maybe it's not in
scope now, but maybe it's something in the
future that could be a value proposition for
KRR and robusta too.
So you're the second person in two days
to say that to me about each of
the group agency.
So I think there is something to it.
It's
not I think in the first drop, we're
gonna be looking at
like, if if I think of how we're
building this, then, okay, we have base recommendations
today.
The next thing to do is to get
better explainability about why we're giving recommendations. We
haven't done. It's, like, really gonna land any
day now.
So you can see that graph. You can
understand why we're recommending what we're recommending and
play with the thresholds if you want to.
And then the next thing, like, the next
level is to be able to say, okay.
I'm not just gonna recommend this output
taking,
like,
a set a fixed request or a fixed
limit. I'm gonna be able to recommend
HPA config. I'm gonna need to recommend the
KDA config and so on. And then for
me, the dev will come like, one beyond
that is then to be able to say,
okay. Now I'm gonna look at when I
optimize this and when I analyze it, I'm
not just gonna look at CPU and memory.
I'm going to be able to take a
look at this bigger or this picture.
And then that's one side of it. And
then the other thing that you touched on
is there's this fundamental relationship between your nodes
and your cluster autoscaler
in between
your pods. And
the good example of that is, like, let's
say we give you a recommendation
that you
should set, I don't know, like, one CPU
and one gigabyte,
but all your nodes have 10 CPUs and
20 gigabytes.
Then based on the ratios, you will always
have wasted memory on your nodes.
So there's a relationship here between scaling your
pods and, like, setting up request and limits
for your pods and between handling
the actual nodes in the cluster autoscaler side.
So that is something we're looking into as
well.
Ah, so, yeah, identifying those parts of memory
that can't be allocated because the CPU is
is utilized.
Right? Or not even utilized, just that it's
been allocated by the scheduler. So it's never
gonna
that RAM's sitting there unless you can get
a workload that actually takes over. Yeah. That's
a nice idea. I like that a lot.
But you have to freeze stuff. So you're
looking at this, like, 10 dimensional problem,
and you can't run on all the dimensions
at once. You have to, like, freeze, like,
nine dimensions and say, okay. Right now, we're
just optimizing for CPU and memory. And then
as time goes on, as you build something
that's more and more complex,
then you start adding more, like,
you start adding, like, more
degrees of control and, like, unfreezing some of
those dimensions.
Yeah. Well, we have a question about one
of those other dimensions, which is important for
our stateful workloads on Kubernetes in the chat.
Russell is asking about tooling that surfaces the
availability of IOPS within container workloads on nodes.
I guess that could be another dimension
that KRR could hook into.
Yeah.
Me.
I hit a nasty issue with this once
where I had a Kubernetes node that was
going
missing an action. It just would suddenly freeze
up on AWS.
And when you looked at it, it was
because it was, like, an AWS node with,
like, a burstable
number of iApps, you used up the burst
quote on the iApps, and the whole node
froze up.
So
I don't I mean, you could get that
in a graph on the dashboard.
Think
the team is adding that to robusta as
well in the dashboards we have.
You can
can you get it
can you get it you can't get it
in KubeCat on top. Right? I don't think
it shows you IOPs.
No. It doesn't. You would have to
yeah. It wouldn't it's not it's not surface
to the metrics server on the KubeLit. So
I don't think, yeah, you're not gonna have
access to them.
And you can get it probably with the
e b b f's based stuff too. Right?
Like, with me.
Yeah. I mean, I I think from the
Kubelet metrics, you may get, like, the flush
time and FSN rules.
I I don't know if you're specifically gonna
get the reason right. It's been a while
since I've dug into that, to be honest.
So I'm not entirely sure. There may be
stuff there, but it may be that you
have to instrument that another way or
use a node exporter from Prometheus to grab
extra metrics there.
Yep.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you so much for
your time today. Is there anything else you
want to cover before we finish up?
Just a request from everyone. Like, this is
new. It's still in beta from our perspective.
So we're testing this out. We're getting feedback
from people, and we're taking all that feedback
to try and make this better.
Like, just this in the past day or
so, got feedback from someone,
who's using this with HPA.
And about an edge case there where, like,
the HPA was trying to drive stuff in
one direction
and was trying to reach 50% utilization, but
the recommendations we were giving were trying to
reach, like, 90 the p 99. Right?
So
we're trying to
really make this, like, the best tool out
there for determining
request and limits on Kubernetes for maximizing utilization
and to do that in an open source
way. But to make it happen,
we need help from everyone out there. We
need feedback. Like, the biggest challenge
when you build an open source project is
that people take your project and they use
it, and they either love it or they
hate it and say, I'm never gonna use
this again, and they just never speak to
you. Whereas if you think of, like, a
company that's sales driven, then it never happens
because you're like, people have to jump on
calls with you and you see the feedback.
And if you give them bad advice, you
hear about it, you give them good advice,
you see they're happy. So I just wanna
request from everyone out there who's listening to
this,
please give us your feedback and open up
GitHub issues, jump on the Slack channels, speak
to us, message me on Twitter or LinkedIn.
We wanna hear from you how we can
make this work for you. And
I'd say the number one thing that I've
learned also as a founder is
when you
like, I can't count the number of times
that I've had someone say to me, you
know,
I guess there is some feedback I could
give, but I think it's only specific to
my company or it's just about how we
work. And then you double click on that,
and you discover it's something that applies to,
like, nine out of 10 people. So even
if it's specific to your company,
speak up and tell us because very often,
it's not just you.
Awesome. Alright, everyone. If you're listening,
go check out the repository on GitHub. Open
up issues with ideas,
bugs,
and make sure you give them as much
feedback as you possibly can.
Oh, we did get a last question sneak
in there right at the end.
Have answer one. I have to address it.
I I have to.
It's an excellent question. And
so let me give background on what Goldilocks
is for people who don't know. So Goldilocks
is
a platform on top of the VPA
that exposes the VPA recommendations
in the web UI,
and they also prevent you from having to
configure a VPA for each and every workload.
So they're doing two things. They're giving you
the VPA recommendations in the web UI,
and they're configuring the VPA for you so
that you don't have to configure it for
each and every deployment in your cluster.
So
I guess the difference
between the
between KRR and the and Goldilocks is the
difference between KRR and the VPA.
And
just to go over that again briefly,
so
we don't require installing anything in your cluster.
You
just run a command line. We take the
historical data, we can give you recommendations immediately.
And
in terms of what we're, like, trying to
accomplish, the the biggest thing that we're trying
to accomplish
is to, one, give explainability.
So not just to give you a recommendation,
but also to show you the data that
supports that recommendation and give you the confidence
to apply that. And that's something
that we're gonna like, just any moment really
something for.
And then the other thing that we're trying
to do is to give more complex recommendations
and, like, analyze this historical data, not just
output a single request or a single limit,
but to be able to output
something that's richer than that, like HPA,
like a Kata config and so on. And
then, of course, in terms of reporting features,
we're
very, like, focused not just on the recommendations,
but how you consume them as well, like
getting a weekly Slack report,
getting the table, like, showing what's the biggest
priority thing to look at and so on.
Nice. Awesome.
Hope that answers your question, Jason.
Like, Goldilocks is good. Like, Goldilocks if you're
using VBA, you should use Goldilocks too.
So
me.
It's not a project I'm familiar with, but
I'll something I'll look into after the stream
and take a look.
Alright.
Thank you again for your time. It's always
fun to see what new ideas you'll come
up with at robusta. Thank you for coming
on to this channel and sharing them with
people. I hope people do get involved open
issues and give you feedback, and hopefully, we'll
see each other against it. So thank you,
Nathan. Have a a wonderful day. And to
everyone that watched, we'll see you next time.
Bye.